lawmakers on Capitol Hill planned to
privately interview former FBI lawyer
Lisa Paige today about her role in the
Russian election probe public
questioning of FBI agent Peter struck
turned into an ill-tempered spectacle
yesterday he testified for the first
time since he was removed from special
counsel Robert Muller's investigation
after sending text messages to Paige
criticizing President Trump during the
campaign Paula Reid is on Capitol Hill
Paula good morning good morning Alex
this hearing was truly remarkable
Peter strut came here to Capitol Hill to
defend himself and the FBI but it
devolved into shouting matches between
the president's supporters and those who
say they support federal law enforcement
highlighting just how contentious the
Russia investigation has become here in
Washington not as to answered little
suspend amidst a fiery hearing that
erupted into multiple shouting matches
it's not a valid point of order denied
Republican lawmakers grilled FBI agent
Peter struck about anti-trump text
messages he exchanged with Paige I don't
appreciate what was originally said
being changed I don't give a damn what
you appreciate agent struck I don't
appreciate having an FBI agent with an
unprecedented level of animus working on
two major investigations during 2016
struck worked on the Clinton email probe
and was one of the lead investigators on
Special Counsel Robert Muller's team but
was removed when the inflammatory text
came to light he sought to explain one
of those text messages in which he
assured Paige that quote will stop Trump
it was in response to a series of events
that included then-candidate Trump
insulting the immigrant family of a
fallen war hero Democrats mocked the
hearing as a joke arguing it was a
distraction from the ongoing Special
Counsel investigation into the president
they need to identify a villain mr.
struck tag you're it
things got personal when struck was
questioned about his extramarital affair
with Paige I can't help but wonder when
I see you looking there with a little
smirk how many times did you look so
innocent into your wife's eyes and
to her about mr. chairman this
outrageous red ability of a witness
North Carolina Republican Mark meadows
admonished his colleague Louie Gohmert
for going there that's a line of
questioning that I would never see is
appropriate struck acknowledged that
claims of bias have hurt the FBI and
undermined its ability to do its job
speaking of jobs struck still could lose
his job with the FBI or face
disciplinary action for those text
messages
bianna quite the explosive hearing Paula
thank you